cuando queremos categorizar la vida como
la conocemos digamos a muy grandes
rasgos podemos dividir en dos categorías
tenemos primero las células eucariontes
esta sería una célula eucariontes y por
otro lado también tenemos las células
provocar y antes muy bien también
tenemos las células provocar y antes y
la diferencia más grande entre estos dos
son las estructuras membrana les de
frontera que los los organismos
eucariontes tienen y los organismos
procariotas no y la más notable de ellas
digamos de estas estructuras es la pared
membrana del núcleo de hecho en un
eucariontes verdad aquí tenemos el
núcleo en una eucariontes la información
genética se encuentra dentro de una
membrana que encierra el núcleo así que
vamos a escribir esto esta estructura
que tenemos aquí es el núcleo de nuestra
célula muy bien de hecho dentro de este
núcleo es en donde podemos encontrar el
a
pero si comparamos por ejemplo con los
organismos procariotas es verdad
entonces podemos ver que el adn se
encuentra acomodado digamos todo se
encuentra acomodado en una sección que
llamamos el núcleo jde pero en esencia
no tiene un núcleo con una frontera
hembra membrana al verdad entonces
podemos decir que los pro calientes
tienen un núcleo tienen un núcleo sin
una frontera membrana al ok sin frontera
membrana
hembra ok y por supuesto no es la única
diferencia entre eucariontes y
procariotas de hecho por ejemplo si nos
remontamos digamos a la etimología de
los eucariontes por ejemplo aquí la
parte digamos que dice que haría antes
verdad se refiere esencialmente a no es
un núcleo que entonces vamos a escribir
esto se refiere esto a no es o bien
puede también digamos interpretarse como
núcleo muy bien por otro lado para los
provocar y antes digamos tenemos esta
parte que dice pro que significa antes
verdad entonces estamos hablando de
antes del núcleo muy bien y por supuesto
no es todas no son todas las diferencias
verdad hay otras estructuras membrana
les que no vas a encontrar en los
propios test por ejemplo aquí tenemos
estas estructuras ver bueno que pinte en
verde verdad estas estructuras de aquí
son
las mitocondrias estas son las
mitocondrias muy bien las mitocondrias
son una estructura que no se encuentran
en los propios tests pero que si se
encuentran en los eucariontes podemos
ver otro ejemplo de estructuras verdad y
lo que tenemos justamente aquí en esta
micrografía verdad en esta micrografía
es el aparato de golgi y el aparato de
golgi esencialmente tiene la función de
empaquetar algunas proteínas de hecho
por ejemplo aquí tenemos una micrografía
de lo que es la mitocondria verdad y
aquí tenemos una micrografía del núcleo
aunque esto exactamente está digamos
está en círculo que se ve muy claro en
la micrografía este es el núcleo verdad
ahí se encuentra la membrana nuclear lo
que acabo de circular y todo el adn se
encuentra digamos pegado aquí en forma
de cromatina verdad y en realidad está
regado por todos lados pero
principalmente en una zona verdad que se
encuentra
aquí que se ve mucho más denso y que se
ve digamos más oscuro verdad entonces a
esta a esta parte se le conoce como el
núcleo lo de hecho es lo que corresponde
por ejemplo a esta zona que tenemos aquí
verdad en esta en este dibujo que tenía
antes y de hecho en el núcleo lo es
donde se produce el arnés ribosomas que
de hecho digamos forma parte de la
estructura de los ribosomas que digamos
son son esenciales en la construcción de
proteínas verdad basados en la
información del arn mensajero y de hecho
esto lo veremos más adelante verdad pero
bueno aquí podemos observar los
ribosomas que están pintados como con
este color naranja
los ribosomas esencialmente están hechos
de rn ribosomas y proteínas y sólo para
ser claros los ribosomas también están
presentes en las estructuras perdón en
las células provocaría antes verdad aquí
también se encuentran los ribosomas así
que la distinción clave entre los
organismos eucariontes
los pro calientes es que en las células
eucariontes hay un núcleo con una
frontera membrana ok y bueno hay otras
diferencias como la presencia de
mitocondrias verdad de hecho hay una
teoría que dice que la mitocondria
evolucionó inicie inicialmente como como
organismos procariotas y que le
empezaron a vivir en simbiosis con las
células eucariontes más grandes ok pero
bueno es una es una teoría muy
interesante ahora bien hay otra
diferencia en las células eucariontes
verdad el adn se encuentra distribuido
digamos como en varias obras ok o en
varios digamos podemos pensarlo en como
en varios hilos verdad mientras que en
las células pro calientes en realidad el
adn es circular muy bien y digo no
necesariamente se tiene que vivir así
podría ser que esté muy enrollado pero
esencialmente termina digamos uniéndose
con el inicio así que en resumen tenemos
tres diferencias la primera diferencia
es que tenemos una membrana nuclear
nuclear perdón y bueno la segunda
diferencia es que tenemos otros
organelos con frontera membrana al por
ejemplo la mitocondria o digamos el
aparato de golgi y la tercera diferencia
es que el adn se encuentra en varias
obras en las células eucariontes
mientras que tenemos adn circular en las
células provocar entes muy bien otra
diferencia por ejemplo entre los entre
los educarían test y los procariotas es
que los eucariontes suelen ser más
grandes que los pro calientes ok de
hecho estos últimos tienden a ser más
pequeños y más simples ahora que ya
sabemos las diferencias digamos las
diferencias principales entre
eucariontes y provocarían test veamos
algunos ejemplos de eucariontes muy bien
así que vamos a hacer esto un poquito
más arriba muy bien aquí tenemos digamos
un primer ejemplo de célula eucariontes
esta imagen de aquí corresponde al
parámetro verdad que de hecho es un
protesta verdad entonces hay algunos
ejemplos de por
mismos unicelulares que pueden ser
eucariontes como el parámetro pero
esencialmente los educarían test también
contienen en esta categoría a los
organismos multicelulares entonces todo
organismo multicelular que es bueno
quizás no todo organismo pero digamos
los más conocidos lo que son las plantas
animales y hongos son organismos
multicelulares que son eucariontes y por
eso tienen membrana celular y otros
órganos bien de hecho por ejemplo aquí
tenemos una imagen en donde podemos ver
las células de la punta de la raíz de
una cebolla muy bien de hecho ésta está
digamos fotografía se utilizó con algún
método de tinción verdad para que puedas
digamos puedan ser teñidos estas estos
circulitos que podemos ver aquí que
esencialmente son los núcleos son los
núcleos y que se ve que están acotados
por la membrana verdad y de hecho esta
es una imagen increíble porque se ven
distintas etapas de la mitosis verdad
que es la división celular esencialmente
verdad
entonces ya hemos dicho en digamos en la
categoría de los organismos eucariontes
podemos encontrar animales hongos
plantas los organismos protistas verdad
y bueno por supuesto podríamos pensar en
lo en en ti mismo verdad en los seres
humanos las células que te hacen ser tú
mismo son células eucariotas ahora bien
veamos algunos ejemplos pro calientes
verdad y esencialmente digamos el
ejemplo más clásico son las bacterias
verdad estas estructuras o estos
organismos que vemos aquí que digamos
tienen forma de píldora estos de aquí
son bacterias muy bien y esos son pro
calientes ahora bien también tenemos
otro tipo de organismos que son las
arqueas y hace muchos años se creía que
eran bacterias que vivían en condiciones
extremas pero ahora sabemos que en
realidad el digamos el dominio de las
arqueas es un dominio distinto de la
vida que no son bacterias muy bien
de hecho hablando de los dominios de la
vida digamos hasta ahora se cree que
digamos la evolución ha sido más o menos
de esta forma que esencialmente tenemos
digamos el dominio de las bacterias muy
bien después tenemos también el dominio
de las arqueas arqueas y por aquí
tenemos también el dominio de los
eucariontes muy bien aquí porque
podríamos pintar el dominio de los
eucariontes
eucariontes y solo para remarcar
recordemos que las bacterias y las
arqueas forman un grupo esencialmente
que son los organismos procariotas
mientras que tenemos otro grupo que son
los educación test así que espero que
este vídeo te haya dado un buen panorama
de cómo son las cosas